our expert committee on the safety of
medicines
the pharmacovigilance and risk
assessment committee has now come to a
conclusion
on the review of cases of blood clots
and people vaccinated with astrazeneca's
cobit-19 vaccine
the committee has come to a clear
scientific conclusion
this is a safe and effective vaccine its
benefits in protecting
people from covet 19 with the associated
risks of death and hospitalization
outweigh the possible risks the
committee
also concluded that the vaccine is not
associated with an increase in the
overall risk of
thromboembolic events or blood clots
now during the investigation and review
we began to see a small number of cases
of rare
and unusual but very serious clotting
disorders and this then
triggered a more focused review
based on the evidence available and
after
days of in-depth analysis of lab results
clinical reports
autopsy reports and further information
from the clinical trials we still
cannot rule out definitively a link
between these cases and the vaccine
what the committee has therefore
recommended is to raise
awareness of these possible risks making
sure that they're included in the
product information
drawing attention to these possible rare
conditions and providing
information to health care professionals
and vaccinated people will help to spot
and mitigate any possible side effects
we're also launching additional
investigations to understand
more about these rare cases and were
conducting
targeted observational studies
over about seven million people have now
been vaccinated in the eu with the
astrazeneca vaccine
and 11 million have been vaccinated in
the uk
in the uk and there is increasing use of
this vaccine in other countries
it remains very important that all side
effects are closely monitored and
reported
so that we can evaluate them and see if
there's any need to update the
information and warnings about possible
risks dr straus will explain the
committee's evaluation in more detail
but i want to reiterate that our
scientific position is that
is that this vaccine is a safe and
effective
option to protect citizens against covet
19.
it demonstrated that at least 60 percent
efficacy in clinical trials and
preventing
coronavirus disease and in fact the real
world
evidence suggests that the effectiveness
could be even higher than that
we're very much aware that some member
states have paused vaccinations
waiting for ema's outcome of a review
but given that thousands of people in
the eu die
every day and in fact over
2500 were reported one day last week it
really was crucial for ema to review
rapidly and thoroughly all the available
evidence
so we made this review our highest
priority
and our experts have worked intensively
to analyze in great detail all the data
available
we have mobilized european experts in
the field of thrombosis
and blood disorders to investigate and
we work closely with other health
authorities across the world
including with the uk's mhra
the scientific conclusions adopted today
provide member states with the
information they need
to take an informed decision regarding
the use of the astrazeneca vaccine
in their in their vaccination campaigns
before i hand over to dr strives i would
like to highlight
that a situation like the one we have
just seen here is not unexpected
when you vaccinate millions of people
it's inevitable that rare or serious
is instances or illnesses will occur
in the in the time immediately following
vaccination
our role in the eu regulatory system is
to rapidly
detect these incidents and investigate
whether there may be a link
to the vaccine or whether they are a
result the result of illnesses which
occur
by chance close in time to the
vaccination
we are committed to ensure that any new
suspected adverse reactions are rapidly
investigated to support
decisions based on science which can
then
support competence in vaccines which is
so important in dealing with this
devastating pandemic that we are facing
and we remain
fully mobilized to to ensure our public
health role
today's conclusion helps us to continue
in the fight against this pandemic by
raising awareness
and providing up-to-date information as
we can
as we have analyzed it and as uh and as
as it becomes available so that so that
citizens across
europe are informed about what they need
to do